hello
is this good qualities
oh good good good I'm glad I'm glad no
potato quality I'm on a brand new iPhone
11 Pro here good quality all right good
good good good is what I like to hear
all right we got some tea and we got
some Lacroix and I'm in my brand new
office so as promised while we wait for
everybody to come in here and join our
amazing coalition of people who are
definitely gonna smack the Buy button on
this product you know you know like I it
is it is really good it is it is a
really good product I wouldn't know this
isn't common prime this products really
good um come on friends okay common
friends okay um phone is getting better
you know common friend but but this one
this one is is is months in the making
we're gonna show you some really cool
stuff that I um I found a quote that was
really inspirational so I wanted to
share that with you guys it's this quote
right here and I'm not sure if it's
backwards
it's first they ignore you then they
laugh at you then they try to copy you
then you change the world and that
quotes by Elizabeth Holmes so you know I
thought I thought that quote was really
inspirational so let's let's go live
live Spain now
yeah I know I'm on a different Street
from the scheduled one I know why wait
I'm watching myself but it's backwards
its backwards on the screen it's
backwards on the screen you can't see it
yeah yeah Elizabeth Holmes you're a
chill driver from Switzerland welcome to
the stream welcome to the stream we got
35 people come in join our broad
coalition of great people in the
community we're definitely gonna smack
the Buy button on this product it's
really no it's not no no no no don't you
know whoa let's go let's go fifty-two
let's go let's go at 3:00 p.m. we are
gonna open the bag you see the bag we're
gonna open the bag at 3:00 p.m.
here's my yawn
this is running open pilot zero point
six point five um you can check out the
beautiful new home screen yeah oh it's
just I don't know final incoming as
YouTube I posted it on this uh yeah no
don't worry I haven't unveiled the
product yet I'm wait until three yeah if
there's no product unveiling we're doing
an office tour and you can see this top
one here and Nabal open violet so if you
have the new hardware this toggle will
work if you don't have the new hardware
you're gonna have to flip switches so
there's that um buy new hardware all
right good
no I didn't what does no new hardware I
didn't jump the gun out into a shed then
do it all right all right let's go can
we ask about self-driving cars in here
absolutely this is finally the place to
do it
you want a tour of common we're gonna go
on a tour we're gonna go on a tour but
first for everyone who hasn't seen no no
I promised the new harbors not canceled
we built a lot of them is really good my
Elizabeth Holmes quote up the name of
the hardware well we can't show you that
well that's a secret all right all right
yes we're finding something out today at
3 o'clock there's a 3:00 p.m. so in five
minutes we're gonna open this bag up
we're gonna put this bag and we're gonna
see the new hardware and this is a neon
this is our old hardware I'll tell you
guys early spoiler 217 people thank you
all for joining this Eon is not going
away
eons are still as relevant as they ever
were but what's in this bag is gonna
make your Eon way better so at 3 p.m.
we'll be opening the bag you'll be like
you know going into this bag we'll be
pulling things out of the bag and we'll
be showing them to you guys with a
medium post we got we got some great
stuff coming and I believe shops gonna
get updated too right away at 3:00 p.m.
so you don't even have to listen to me
talk you can just smack that Buy button
as soon as it goes live huh Jack died my
chat die wait what a chat Bert what a
chat break chat disconnected this is
terrible YouTube oh yeah no no we're
good we're good we're good
oh yeah oh yeah a chats back alright
let's do it let's do we got 245 people
get everybody in here 248 248 and we're
gonna be in just four minutes reaching
into this bag and looking at the latest
hardware okay I let me just remind
myself what it oh that's that's pretty
nice
well that's that's a nice Wow that's
that's pretty nice oh yeah that's that's
good that's good stop GBC yarn is not
for sale alright but this is my new
office so you guys I hope you like it I
have my own office now these are my
books this is my television it's not
connected to anything yet this is my
couch so we go over here and we just
chill baby chill we wait for stuff we
talk to people yeah so that's my
office and that's my whiteboard yeah my
Elizabeth Holmes quote I find it really
inspirational every time I think about
that I might be doing badly at startup I
just remembered the rao's and I know
that I'm not doing badly because we're
making real money for real people like
you guys today we're gonna hit the Buy
button on the car harness oh whoa whoa I
said the name of the product oh I
shouldn't have done that
that's a leak I get the black bear oh
yeah you'll give my ship in a black bag
don't like this one but but we're gonna
open this bag I'm gonna just reach in
here I'm gonna just what I can't show
you the product now it's uh we also got
two minutes
yeah we're breaking YouTube we're
breaking YouTube all right no no she
lives in a San Francisco with her with
her new boyfriend and her wolf dog
that's what I heard
all right this is not Elizabeth home
stream this is a comma a I stream we're
we're announcing a new product in just
two minutes
in just two minutes so stay tuned here
let's play the jeopardy music that's
what I like to do when I wait jeopardy
music alright let's go 30 second timer
with jeopardy music 30 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're going live in just a
few minutes no guys I'm actually this
isn't I'm actually psyched for this
product you guys it's good it's good I
wouldn't tell you if it was good if it
wasn't good umm it's it's it's really
it's not just it's not just oh what's in
the bag
we need 420 viewers yo you'll get people
in here call up your friends tell them
Commons if I have to reveal what's in
this bag in just five five minutes but 5
min how many minutes that I said I know
we're still getting people I think we
gotta wait I don't think we can do it at
exactly 3 I think we're gonna have to go
to a commercial break first ah look we
got we got tea we got Lacroix mmm okay
oh it's live it's live I'm in a shop is
it live on the shop live on the shop you
go oh it's live in the shop it's live on
the shop okay at 3:00 p.m. okay let's go
let's open this bag up congratulations
welcome to our hardware future um we
also have a medium post let's just can
we go live with that as well if you guys
out there at comma watching live team if
you could just go live at the video post
so people can can read along at home
actually know what I can do it right
here but that's boring you guys came
here to watch me pull things for the
back so we're gonna start with this here
this is the car harness well the whole
thing is called the car harness first of
all but this wire is a replacement for
the giraffe so you see we have different
wires Honda Bosch Toyota Honda Knight AK
instead of needing all that complexity
that used to be in a giraffe I don't
even have a giraffe I'll show you one
later they were terrible the giraffe was
the worst product comet ever made and I
really think that the car harness is new
product right now is the best so you see
this is a car harness on this side we
have a brand new connector we're
introducing right here this is obd see
it uses a USBC cable plugs right in
there like us this 26 pin connector is
open source will explain to you what it
is in the medium post but if you want to
add a new car to open pilot to the
common eco system you'll just have to
make a wire these wires are super easy
to make
this is all available on digital
I would just take the Toyota wire and
click it right in here to my car harness
like this a little good to go now you'll
see that there's another port here -
this is an Ethernet port it connects
with an Ethernet cable you know you plug
the ethernet cable in here cut the other
end the ethernet cable see how it's flat
it beautifully tucks into the trim of
your car and it connects to the cama
power v to remember the terrible white
comma power super light really ugly this
is the replacement reliable and it
doesn't just have power it also has
can 424 viewers that's higher than the
price that yuan was gonna take Tesla
private act let's go 429 welcome welcome
for those of you just joining the stream
the product is called the car harness oh
yes and the most wonderful thing that I
didn't even talk to you guys about this
harness it's entirely underneath your
trim so you can take this and in all of
the supported cars if you buy the
harness the correct one for your car
you'll be able know it's the price a
typo no way it's not cheap you know this
is quality stuff well we haven't gotten
to all of it yet it's not just this
we're still gonna pull one more thing
from the back but yeah so this is a
Toyota cable plug it in here USBC cable
, power v2 which doesn't just do power
it also does kin so fingerprinting 2.0
is going to read the VIN from the car so
this will just go in here like this and
then you have a complete set where does
this cable connect you might ask to the
greatest part of the car harness it's
this the black panda the black panda has
all of the great stuff from a gray panda
this has a high-precision GPS inside of
it and I'm gonna take you guys live to
the manufacturing oh we can go look at
this stuff this has four canned
transceivers this is the part you're
paying for USB C plugs in right here and
of course you can take an Ethernet cable
USB mini USB cable this is a commis maze
also available for sale in the shop
plugs right in here or you can just use
a normal USB cable you don't achieve
this maze I just don't have one and it
plugs right in here to your complete
this is the v2 hardware system are they
in stock and ready to ship well if you
order today and you're one of the first
50 people to order will ship it out on
Monday so yes they're in stock and ready
to ship and we're gonna go look at that
right now
this is a car harness and maybe now we
can roll to the video that shows the
harness off is the medium post live no I
don't think it is
let's just go live with the medium post
here called our Hardware future that
just basically goes over what we talked
about and we're gonna watch a quick
video I'm gonna flip cameras so we can
watch this video yeah this is the
harnessed trailer yo I hope you guys
enjoy whoops got to make sure we got
sound yeah yeah there we go
wait let's rewind all of this for the
low low price of 399 if you think it's
high it's gonna go up so buy today the
black Panda the greatest Panda calm a
eyes ever made
[Music]
yeah um if you guys are enjoying videos
we also have a full v2 hardware
installation video linked from the
medium post shows you just how easy it
is to install but you guys can launch
that on your own ok let's look at the
inspirational Elizabeth Holmes quote for
a little bit that's good and now let's
go on a factory tour
[Music]
first we're gonna take you to the left
here a testing closet this is the
company's predictions for how many car
harnesses we're gonna sell they range
from 15 to 99 so please get your order
in today for our harness that's live at
shop tower comedy guy this is our
testing closet where we test yawns we've
been testing car harnesses now for over
a month this is the most well tested
caught a hardware that kamas ever
shipped let me see if I can bring the
comments up here so I can see them
comments top chat live chat oh yes here
we go your yes perfect and now we're
gonna take you guys live to the factory
floor where these products are being
made so you'll see we have black rock
pandas encased right here this is a
black Panda you'll see it includes a GPS
some can transceivers there some can
transceivers there and upgraded inductor
this is uh no more power issues for your
Aeons corolla hybrids are going to be
fixed with fingerprinting 2.0 so this is
what a black panda looks like without a
case this is a gps antenna it's already
built in to the complete black panda
here so i think if i open this guy up i
don't to break it these things are very
expensive it includes the gps antenna so
this is everything
wait it's flipping this is everything
that's in a grey panda just in a much
smaller case
this here is kama powers ready to ship
power v twos
these are car harnesses you can check
them out they're sort of beautiful no
scam it's all real it's all right here
for you today we can go down here we can
see all the wire so giraffes are being
discontinued powers are being
discontinued you need hardware too if
you have any questions about it you need
hardware to buy hardware to today oh
yeah check it out you only want it if
it's real that's right it is real this
is where I make it some more eons always
making some more eons these are called
powers without they're beautiful cases
um if you want to right now you might be
in the first 50 I don't know how quick
these sold these are antennas yeah cool
guys
oh yeah wait is that part of the oh we
should talk about that I thought there
was only four people who got the email
Oh yo yo if you guys buy a shirt with it
it's only three dollars yeah ninety
percent off I said it all wrong Wow
someone should have given me talking
points for this I'm worse than I'm worse
than than you know when those guys go on
late-night TV and don't know what
they're talking about Oh
90% off get your t-shirt right now
that's crazy you already bought yours
well you know what it's great it's great
it's only 399 do we have anything we
want to show them oh we got something
special what do we got oh I don't
remember where are they
why we showed them the wires is it do I
know about this oh the boss one oh yeah
oh it's $30 but you got to use the promo
code shirt yo is that real plastic this
is a real Bosch connector no more 3d
printed they work great Bosch harness
Subaru harness and FCA harness coming
soon but for now everybody who has a
Honda night act a Honda Bosch Toyota it
does work in Russia make sure to buy one
cool wow we got 459 people here
pedals no we don't sell paddles but oh
yeah by the way if you just split the
Ethernet it'll work with a pedal it
works perfectly with the pedal just
split the ethernet should we well so do
you know the harness is cheap to make
but the the black pan does not so cheap
black pan is a great oh the discount
code doesn't work do you want to go to
our sales team and and complain mmm hey
Alex they say the discount code doesn't
work code works fine nevermind
I just didn't know how to use it yeah
just bought it alright should we see how
many were sold how do you get a shirt
with no more switches no more switches
yeah if your stuffs less than a month
old you can return it we have a 30-day
return policy on everything so if you'd
like to send back your giraffe and your
other Panda and it's been only 30 days
of course we honored the return policy
here yeah so giraffes powers pause pause
now paws are gone paws are still here no
pause actually work with black pandas
two giraffes are over powers are over
pandas gray pandas look how many gray
pandas we have left that's right none
them because the black Panda is a far
superior product to the gray panda let's
go take another look at it if you return
it smash you don't get your money back
oh but yeah let's go take another look
at the black kinda you know you might
think that you know because it's small
it's not powerful I promise you it's
powerful
there's no GM version uh right now
better USBC than Raspberry Pi for right
oh my you guys you guys that's today's
sales oh I'm so happy you guys are
applying them oh this is incredible this
is incredible we made ten grand today yo
we're gonna break the record of 26 grand
or what 26 grand is the all-time ,
record oh man this products a hit that's
right that's right oh they're so nice
they're really nice they really are
beautiful and if you're one of the first
50 to buy
you'll get it shipped out on Monday it's
Kama pedal compatible you just need to
get an Ethernet splitter you just need
that one wire down super good whoo
21 sales all right there's no new
functionality oh I didn't even tell you
guys about the functionality no there's
new functionality okay do you know about
cruise fault do you know when you have
to take your car and you have to power
cycle the car because it has a cruise
fault error because your Aeon was turned
off that doesn't happen anymore inside
of this harness is advanced relay
technology this is all fixed you can
unplug your Aeon and it just switches
right back to stock that is one of the
great things fixed on our hardware v2
system also you see these little loop
wires right here no dip switches the
relays are not optically isolated
there's no reason to do that um but it
is advanced for you like technology I do
promise um you have to add the shirt to
the car and thing to the cart you can't
just get the shirt oh if that's what
you're trying to do you're cheating you
got to buy a harness if you want to get
a 90 percent off shirt no crews fault
completely still this stuff fits
entirely inside your your trim um too
late to get shirt well send us an email
if you send an email to support we'll
add a shirt on afterwards we did
announce that too late that was because
I'm the worst talk-show host ever
a Lima gonna thank you thank you thank
you 463 people everybody go out there if
you have an e on you buy a black panda
today comes with all of this you're not
gonna regret it you're gonna love the
way your car looks you're not gonna lose
that piece of plastic that comes with
the car because you can reinstall
everything on the car stock if you pull
the USBC cable out of your black panda
or if you pull the USB cable out of your
black pen if you pull either one of
these cables out your car will revert to
stuff there's also a toggle added on
zero point six point five that can rien
a ball open pilot where you can switch
the stock right like that say you know
your wife drives a car your friend
drives a car you want to disable open
pilot just disable compile it right like
that
and this Aeon will turn right to dashcam
mode check out the beautiful new screen
this of course ships to everybody if you
don't have come a crime and you live in
the US this is an ad for comma Prime we
love ads but if you buy a black panda
today you're getting with the hardware a
v2 program also if you have an old
Toyota giraffe well you'll see what the
problem is
you're probably gonna definitely want to
buy a harness um because you're gonna
get everything fixed up you're gonna get
your high beams back you're gonna get
you a TV back that's all gonna be fixed
oh man wait who said twenty one orders
you got way more than twenty one orders
we got a crazy amount of orders guys
look at what we're at right now we're at
12440 four dollars you guys right now
can help us break this record 26,000 is
the record from July 4th by a black
panda today you're getting with the
future I promise you prices are not
gonna go down prices only go up you know
I've been I've stuck to that he owns
have gone up white pandas have gone up
this is the cheapest you're gonna be
able to get a black panda for so make
sure if your
by one buy it today you're gonna love it
and you know it just gets you with the
new v2 hardware
notice that this thing is not called the
black Panda where the car horn is this
is called our Hardware future giraffes
and pandas were v1 Khmer whoo Chris
thank you um what about Ford's IDs you
were no DSU I mean it works with both um
we just put a white fan of twenty to
thirty four days ago you're a little Oh
any updates yeah zero point six point
five is going out to develop I mean this
stuff's all cheap this stuff's wires but
what you really binds a black panda
right here black panda has got an entire
gray panda fit in here
in addition to you know how hard it is
to make it so you can plug the cable in
this way or this way real hard but we
did it we did a great job with the
engineering of course all the code on
the black band is completely open-source
github.com such come any I slash panda
the real takeaways here are if you have
do the email go out did you guys get the
email um Oh II on v2 and yeah yeah black
pant
that's where it's at alright let's see
let's see what we got let's see let's
see how many orders we got how are we
doing how we doing on sales have we here
oh one more salem we're gonna cross
13,000 one more sale we're changing the
game guys what this is doing what this
system really is what hardware v2 really
is this stuff you know the ethernet
cable you won't even see any of this all
that's gonna come out of your car
is this and this is a USBC cable we've
created a custom protocol for it called
obd see ODBC this is the future of
interfacing with your car this has fork
and buses on it relay control and
started detection yeah we're gonna use
iphone 11 pros we are just like bit
connect except we're not a scam and if
you buy one of these will actually send
you something oh it's only three
ninety-nine
it is only to aetherium it's it's like
none of a Bitcoin I wish it was less
aetherium which aetherium was worth more
but now you know you can't have
everything can it start the car
well okay so the other thing that this
has that the old stuff did not is so
this is a common power as you can see
there's five pins on here two grounds
one power and to camp so the black panda
has four canvases and the fourth canvas
allows you to talk to this the canvas on
the OBD so if your car has lock and
unlock support from from like the the
tools that it comes with like Honda has
HDS Toyota has t is you couldn't sniff
that figure out what can come and was
sent and then you'll be able to unlock
your car alive overcome a crime all
right and that's where this is going
that's one of the reasons we added the
canvas here we can also do
fingerprinting 2.0 so for the Corolla
hybrid for the Honda clarity there were
a few cars that broke fingerprinting 1.0
they're all gonna work and
fingerprinting 2.0 and you're gonna need
this hardware OB DC OB DC why does car
horn is a separate unit not integrate
into black panda this hides underneath
your trim this does not this needs to be
on the windshield cuz it has a GPS
inside of it whoa whoa guys guys what is
that what does that say remember when I
thought we were getting a smash the
record we're gonna obliterate it yo know
if you haven't placed your or yet 437
people get in right now I think you will
still be okay so so this is this is real
talk I'm not even making this up I'll
prove it to you 33 total orders the next
17 people who order will be in the first
50 and you'll get it on Monday um if you
order after that it'll ship later that's
how many we can make this week we can
make about 50 a week us PC with can is
odbc yes it is what is my role at common
today I am the president
I am the president
that means
I'm but I'm not like one of those
democratically elected presidents I'm
like one of those you know like like the
president of something that has a lot of
like Democratic and people's in the name
yeah that's that's what I'm president of
um so I am here today and I am honestly
telling you that this stuff is the
future of the comic ecosystem I was not
this hyped on the prime talk I was not
this ibed because we've been working on
this for like a long time now we were
gonna launch something similar to this
but not as good three months ago and I
just got mad and said this is this is
total crap we're gonna cancel that and
we're gonna do it well and this is the
one that's done well I will forward be
in the ecosystem soon Florida has a 10
second lockout problem probably no other
new fusions I think we can add for it
back in and it'll be super easy to just
design a new 26 pin cable that works
with Ford John dies so if you buy the
comma harness um we can ship you send an
email to support about it we'll ship you
one of these with just wires so you'll
have to get the connectors for the car
yourself but it's fairly Universal
actually looking at that post on the
medium post is pretty good so let's just
let's just turn around here and take a
look at this so this is the pin outs of
the cable um so this this is this cable
right here faces like this um so this is
what you'll need to wire up your own car
most cars are wired like this the car
connects to the camera connects to the
radar so you can just wire it up like
that it's pretty easy if you've got a
carp or Nissan Rogue support coming VW
coming yeah I mean what this is allowing
us to do
Hyundai is actually in official open
pilot right now we're gonna try to make
you and I dongles I'm gonna try to make
these for you and I right now we've just
made the three most common but uh
oh yeah and these are all the we're
gonna open source the wiring diagrams
for these we want to make it easy for
people to add new cars to our ecosystem
the camera shaking sorry GM GM is coming
Nissan Rogue yes absolutely yeah third
party can absolutely make these wires
and sell them yeah my happy hacking
keywords beautiful I let's
oh my god guys guys 15700 36th only 14
more people are gonna get in yo well i
autograph the first 50 hundred no I'm
not willing to sell myself out like that
gotta have some standards but I will
appreciate you and love you forever
whatever that means
black panda coke dude I sniff you know
you know some people are excited about
black pandas I've been working on this
for three months post shop info on
Twitter
yeah can we close the shop info on on
Twitter we also post that installation
video on Twitter if you guys are out
there listening oh I guess well you get
there waiting for the livestream to be
over but yeah yeah let's start let's
start posting that stuff um what T am i
drinking it's green green tea I don't
know my friend made it for me the
clarity will be officially supported I
believe I think the clarity is only
problem is fingerprinting the common
power is included and yes it's required
no we're not clearing out we're actually
almost out of stock of gray pandas how
much longer will the OGE on work in the
comic ecosystem for a while for a while
we're not planning defecate that anytime
soon what will be deprecated first is
white pandas and giraffes and gray
pandas right now there's no reason for
us to break them but once fingerprinting
1.0 becomes too hard to maintain future
versions of volton pilot are only gonna
work with the black panda and only gonna
work with fingerprinting 2.0 um no so
this actually has a built-in gps antenna
already um
by the way I've been working on this the
company has been working on this for
three months when you actually make a
product nice
we have installation videos it takes a
lot of time however we decode in the VIN
we're building a big lookup table we do
ship to Sweden we ship worldwide you
gotta pay for shipping free shipping in
the US though so if you're in the u.s.
get in right now get your free shipping
oh man are we gonna smash the sales
record live on this stream we're up to
seventeen thousand six hundred and fifty
eight dollars if we get that above
twenty six you guys are setting the
all-time one-day sales record for koumei
i will there be updates to the porting
guy
it doesn't change that much
fingerprinting that the whole notion of
fingerprinting and having to add a
fingerprint is gonna go away with the
black panda and fingerprinting 2.0 and
we're gonna build that on the server
side yeah I know that hockey stick right
well who was buying anything today when
the new product was coming out at 3:00
right that's like somebody who buys the
iPhone X the morning the iPhone 11 comes
out um the new Jeep Wrangler I believe
so I think that the jeeps are supported
we're gonna do FCA dongles pretty soon
we're gonna roll out FCA dongle and
Subaru dongle next um yeah you need to
buy more Toyota's what's the code the
code is shirt if you just put in shirt
you can get a three dollar shirt that's
ninety percent off on shirts that's the
cheapest shirt you can't even buy shirts
from street vendors in New York for that
cheap um can we just spin
he's been spamming scam I mean you know
not everybody can be helped
he said VW coming yeah yeah we're doing
we're doing VW I know you need more
torques we've been talking about the
torque situation we know and actually if
there's ever any firmware updates see
they can be pushed right here through
this obd you can't using the fourth cam
available only on black panda all their
pandas only had three cans black panda
is the first with four camps that's one
more cam what about that conversation
about cooling the EON well you know now
it's easy to take the eon off when you
take the eon down it's not gonna cause
any loose fault problems on your car
it's really easy all the link is on
twitter the link is on twitter comic our
harnesses are available now let's we got
we got some great video content to we
did uh yeah it's one more can yes/no
promo code today so the promo code guys
i'm gonna paste it right here is
shirt is 90% off shirt with black with
car harness purchase yeah I've ever
thought about working for the Chinese
government no Mazda is also happening
yeah no great job mmm I wish I
remembered his name but there's someone
who discord have been working really
hard on the Mazda 4 we really want to
get that upstream it's incredible how
far this community has grown in the last
limit let me let me shout out when he
shout out the Mazda port I think we've
gotten that already up streamed into
Panda and that's Mazda Jafar
yes Jafar all he's been he's been
working on the Mazda and it looks really
good and shout out to Angela for making
my office beautiful can we link her can
we link her can we can we give love to
everybody what car should we select for
other cars um we should have launched
with that we should have launched with
that I'm sorry we didn't that'll be up
in a bit
don't buy back the cathode is an extra
work recently right guys we're winning
we're winning key is it's all coming all
the other cars are coming it's gonna be
so easy for us because the harness is
the same for all cars the black Panda
the same for all cars power the same for
all cars the only thing that changes is
these and we're gonna get lots of
different ones that I made if Eon is
dead yes it'll automatically switch if
your Eon is dead it'll automatically
split from stock you don't have to shut
the car off this will just automatically
happen Dodge Challenger probably not
eighties Volvo oh yeah we've left that
in Vegas with some guy who tried to give
us Walmart gift cards for Real Talk , is
yes we're gonna go for an hour with this
stream so if anybody has any questions
I'm happy to talk about the comedy
ecosystem and really this someone said
it I mean all our future products are
gonna work with this same obd seek and
there that works on the black panda so
it's gonna be the same connector it's
gonna be the same harness you're only
ever gonna have to take your trim off
once no it's not USBC power delivery
protocol it's we put 12 volts on the
USBC don't plug this into a phone it's
actually pretty safe in most phones but
don't plug it into a phone I'm how good
is comma Prime is it really worth it
well it is exactly what it is you have
to make your own decision about whether
it's worth it some people really think
it is um black panda definitely worth it
come a prime also big feature coming
next year like an unreal feature so you
know you can always you can always hold
off till next year when we up the price
and you'll have to pay more per month
but you know the new panda has hired a
powerup but yeah
um so it has a it hasn't much better
switching power supply brilliant new
hardware engineer routed it for us it's
good uh I sold uder and that's what I
like to hear [ __ ] black pandas let's
see what the sales are up to
yo yo we're gonna smash that record
we're gonna smash that record you can
still get in right now and be one of the
first 50 we got 47 orders today
hey I'm crying right now I mean no it's
it's useful so it's unlimited day that
we fixed heathering in in zero point six
point five we are adding a new feature
soon gonna be snapshots you're gonna be
able to take a picture from your Aeon
right from the app we're making the app
like more interoperable with comm Prime
who's winning the bat in the office well
we already have some losers as to who's
gonna win I don't know but we can go
look at that board let's go let's go
back to the testing closet and take a
look at that losses um where's that with
the marker gotta go find the marker
let's go get a marker what oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah Harold down here guessing um
15 we're just gonna cross that one off
Andy with 27 that can go up 42 can go 32
can go 37 can go all right all right all
right so we got viv
right now we got Willem with 55
I guess 69 guys I'm just I'm just I
guess 69 and we got way Shing here with
77 and we got Greg down here with 99 so
will it be bibley 47 that's if nobody
else buys one will it be willing with 55
will it be me with 69 will it be wasting
with 77 or will it be Greg with 99 yo
let's see how many result ETA to
profitability our estimate actually was
selling 50 of these so we've already
crushed that estimate I'm super happy
with all of you
well we're hoping also 0.7 i'm software
coming to all the Aeons is gonna be
really good 0.6 did wonders for our
sales our revenue growth is up 50% from
q2 to q3 we'vewe've 50% upped our
revenue if we do 50% again in q4 or a
profitable company 0.65 0.65 isn't in
devel let me check 0.65 not in de valera
know why but uh coming soon a Comi UPS
firmware might happen uh let's see car
horn this is at 43 well oh it's at 43 or
what about the other ones
no we've already sold seven them right
those ones aren't included but those
ones aren't included in the first 50
that are gonna ship so if you get your
order in right now when are you gonna
get a consumer product so consumer
products are you journey not a
destination if Apple called the iPhone a
consumer product and said it was over uh
it'd be over but Apple worked tirelessly
to make 11 in iPhones and that's how
many aeons we're gonna have to make but
the final one's gonna drive your car
right full self-driving um what car
should you buy for kamma
toyota corolla toyota corolla is the
best car it does work in the UK driving
on the left china but no it does
actually there's some great people a
privacy policy comedy i / terms I
believe it's linked from the set up a
boat of the app which you can download
for free so that's probably the best
place to lock but if you're asking that
question yeah we sense flow oh you wanna
see the data center let's go to the data
center guys um we're just gonna take
we're gonna take this black panda with
us in my pocket so we can we can see the
black panda everywhere let's go to the
data center the data center is really
cool we do our training in-house because
the cloud is an overpriced scam so we're
just gonna bring you guys over here like
this
so we're gonna see a few cool things as
we enter the cama garage
it's loud in here we got a rav4 you can
see ignore the terrible looking white
table but that's a black Panda right
there on the windshield beautiful setup
we've been testing him for months
here's our wall of printers where
everything is printed
[Music]
and here is our data center I'm very
proud of it Gregg's worked super hard on
it all of this is our data Wow
two of them are broken and these here
are forty ten atti GPUs these are our
random server computers and this is our
working data storage yes if someone
parks badly that's the end of the data
center in the printers it's true that's
why we have open pilot we have secret
good open pilot that does parking for us
check it out black panda cases beautiful
[Music]
a stock a baby with harness yes unless
you unplugged your GSU or I have a GM
without a SEM there were all Linux
simulators coming along great yeah it
does right and show you guys the secret
code oh you guys want to see look at
that fan the clouds a scam oh man
well that's sketchy don't touch it don't
touch it
behind the door wires and a big fan
oh my god that's the hell is sketchy
if you're concerned about privacy and
your data is here
look at them blinking they look
beautiful no no in San Diego now just
bought alright that's what I like to
hear
all right we got we got 14 more minutes
in the live stream do we record audio at
all no not at all and the front camera
is optin so by default we don't record
the front camera either oh yeah we got
it we got good locks and we got theft
insurance
I hate crime and that's why we moved to
San Diego because this lot was crime
here in San Francisco check it out we're
building some new Aeons these are
actually gonna be throwback eons we're
gonna do some some og eons 128 gigabyte
we got the last stock of the 1 pluses
Tarana was less crime yeah but it's in
Canada it's cold black pandas open
source no the hard was not open source
did we pass 25 k let's go check oh yes
Python 3 on 0 6 5 so we're really moving
to the future wide my mind change on the
firmware there was yeah I don't know
some of you might know some of you might
be able to figure will get and break the
record today we're gonna break the
record I actually think that we can
subtract some of those were yawn orders
so you might still get in the first 50
if you go today rip stream no no
connection come back No uh can you make
a legal request to receive and download
all your data mean you can try this is
why we've started deleting data it's
back excellent excellent we're at
$23,000 guys I'm gonna stick you know
what I said it was gonna be an hour but
I'm gonna stick with the stream until we
smash the record let me let me get I
posted what the exact record was and
staff yesterday you know
our slack let's see what it is no I
actually didn't post it because I was
concerned we weren't gonna break it but
now I know that we are so let's go look
at the end well we're looking at it I
can show you a video of installation
[Music]
23700 26,000 $740 mr. Curt what's up
[Music]
yeah yeah if they got an impatience and
they wanted an yeah I'm cool with that
yeah you got a you gotta give the
t-shirt size - yes oh yeah oh yeah
22,000 24266 whoa if you buy it now you
get an FCA connector later wait till the
FCA connectors ready
no our investors are not pressuring me
to make money
definitely not I'm pressuring everybody
to make money because if we make money
we prove that the idea is great and we
hire more people we get better models
you know money guys look at me we're
gonna we're gonna flip around and we're
gonna do a look at me we're almost at 69
now we just moved down here we moved to
a beautiful new office
can't vest not looking to raise money
[Music]
Zor tracks em to hundreds
[Music]
pick me back to it you can read the code
don't think so
unless they snuck past me stick a sturdy
box International shipping purchase is
really hard investment to the company I
do live in San Diego I live in a
beautiful apartment watch me on Twitch
if you want to see it's super easy to
set up
[Music]
that clouds not a scam
it doesn't matter that much the GPS is
only good to a meter so thank you
uh yeah we don't know yeah he knows talk
to private company but I'll say that's
look all the money we make
so someone someone wants I think it was
a youtube comment where it was like you
know about me like this guy wants to be
a billionaire so bad what would I do
with a billion dollars well buy ya know
every dollar that , AI makes just goes
back into the company right like there's
no people taking profit off of the table
if we make more money we're a 13-person
company now you know why we're not a
huge company like like like tzuke's and
like cruise because those companies lose
billions of dollars every year we're not
only gonna win self-driving cars we're
gonna do it with a profitable company
um we're gonna sell stuff that actually
provides value to you if I didn't think
open pilot Act I'm thinking about
getting a new car I don't want to get
Toyota I don't want to get a Honda but I
don't know if I could get a car without
open pilot is it Toyota Corolla with
open pilot better than an Audi a4 I
think it is take my shirt off whoo if we
get the 69 I mean how many hours a day
do we work yeah what'swhat's the know we
work normal schedules grow roll the life
have some basic Carver 1k I buy that yes
I still work a comma yes um a Camry with
open paws that in the name for I really
think that's true and that just says
like you're really getting this product
for so cheap compared to the value that
it adds we're gonna cross 25,000 soon
we're at twenty four six six eight and
where's three payments to capture well I
think those are the people who bought
shirts
wait unfulfilled what why oh I don't
know
26000 guys you guys we might even do it
in the hour this is insane
how do I cover my personal expenses I'll
tell you my salary I make $80,000 a year
that's legit my salary oh yeah yeah we
might run out of t-shirts so if you want
a t-shirt
yeah you better you better get it now
what's the no free lunch theorem you can
google it well no no free lunch and
search an optimization we're talking
about that today at lunch yeah the
company pays my salary of course but
like I'm saying like I'm not taking
millions off the table here right
actually I love a salary at the company
now um some people got raises recently
so now I mean you know
how do you get I have personal money I
have other money too not related to
comma I make money streaming on twitch
twitch deep got TV slash George Hotz and
soon I'm gonna be an Instagram
influencer and then I'm gonna make buku
bucks and I'm gonna buy a yacht just
kidding
now I'm not CEO I'm president if you if
you come to work here
you'll get salary choices and the lowest
one is ATK come if you want the highest
equity we do pay inequity yeah so
actually really the only way to invest
in comma the only way to get common
equity now is to come work here nope no
CEO can you work there as a mascot you
see if we sold two hundred thousand
dollars of sales today maybe then we
could afford a mascot
I'm the discount code for ninety percent
off of a shirt is shirt oh yeah I could
make two hundred k plus yeah beforeand
ok um look I don't even know what I do
with money man whatever and then way mo
wins that's no fun we live in a fun
world what I look for in engineers yeah
knowing everything um we don't really do
like we develop open pilot right we're
not looking to make sketch business
deals we sell this like it's foreign
dollars you see exactly what it is
we're totally transparent about it
where's open sources we can be why can't
see a knock anything at because there's
fork and buses on here um plus power
plus ground so that's ten pins plus star
to detect plus relay trigger so it's 12
pins so you got a 12 pin ethernet lying
around somewhere even it's a pro tip
guys we just broke the record we just
broke the record
highest sales day in comma a I has a
yeah yeah so we really are gonna be done
wow we're gonna be done we're gonna be
done in an hour so it's gonna be an hour
long stream virtually Chris thank you do
we have anything else to do I think we
broke the record I think we only got
three more minutes road to 30k guys I'm
happy wrote the record we solved a lot
and I think 69 might be pretty glutton I
think watchett 800 more um could I live
stream the celebration tonight maybe
yeah well higher we're actually we're
hiring for two positions right now we're
hiring an open pilot developer I'm
hiring a research engineer I'm so open
pilot developer we're looking for
someone with assistive background Python
background someone who's really gonna
make open pilot super stable wants to
work on testing we're also hiring a
research engineer to work on the desire
problem um so if you guys read the open
pilot code and look at desire especially
people writing Forks you might be very
interested in what that is desire is one
of the craziest things we're doing here
and it's really a big step on our way to
do self driving but I can't say full
self drive we build level t-28s systems
show books will show one book so we'll
show one book let's take a good book
that's a good book yeah yes information
theory inference and learning algorithms
super important stuff to know this is
cool to home graph complexity we're
talking about this at lunch this has to
do is no free lunch stuff twenty-seven
thousand three hundred and three dollars
give me a job coming down AI that's
where you apply um smart Salman is a
gimmick you don't want that will do red
lights and stop signs before we do smart
something about that uh is everyone
making the same effective calm poll if
you got an earlier you got more equity
some people opted for higher salaries
some people opted for higher equities
it's pretty fair mmm
did I just show for that book I don't
make any money off those books uh
actually the information dirty book is
free as well I bought just disappoint
the guy I like the author he's dead now
though so I don't know if you own this
bought him anymore will you get rich
working a comma if you're coming here to
get rich you probably won't fit in well
you might though but if that's your goal
go work and Finance breath you'll make
more money in finance you really well
but you know you won't change the world
and grow slowly prisoner of resources
and wait for all the companies to crash
next yeah oh oh you need to raise 1.3
billion dollars to keep your company
around bro see I'm just happy making
mine making my twenty seven thousand
three hundred dollars today thank you to
everybody who some days I leave work
smiling some days they don't it depends
if it works today I'm gonna leave work
smiling cuz we broke the record whoo
it's common profitable yet Q for this
year we're going for it hopefully
hopefully we saw 50% growth from q2 to
q3 we're hoping for another 50% growth
q3 q4 and this starts with the harness
and the black Panda
I mean Records not broken yet you mean
of course the records broken
I just sold another 120 7705 how does
the black pan to interact with the
Toyota TSU if you have your D s you
disconnected the stock Watauga won't
work unfortunately follow distance
reduction you don't yeah wait for
end-to-end longitudinal do I think being
open source will make it hard to compete
with other companies with significant
capital I think a lot of those companies
are just throwing capital away
they are absolutely throwing capital
away there are companies who are so much
better funded than us that have code
that's worse than open pilot we do take
interns we take interns year-round it's
a three month internship program again
the talent bar is quite high but if you
have a good github you have a good like
math and physics background will
absolutely take you as an intern sales
are good but how many could be returns
we get a lot of returns lower than the
industry I think I returned it was like
5% once people get open pilots set up in
their car and no one returns it um how
do I get a merge request approved give
me the poor first kamidana we're pretty
good oh that was mistaken the record has
been broken guys the record has been
broken and ten longitudinal next year
we'll ship to the Aeons but let's first
you know zero point six point five
should be in de val any minute now I'm
not sure why it's not I'll find that out
as soon as we stop the stream allied are
in math companies then someone's it for
a sad reckoning um except your pull
request with the Subaru we're gonna get
serious about Subaru we ship the Subaru
connector um what happens with Young's
run out we make more eons always more
eons now when I explain the Untied
longitudinal now that'll be for another
day we don't exactly know how it works
yet we've been trying some very basic
experiments right now
sup Jeff rocks we make DI yeah you can
make DIY connectors we've we've checked
the medium post you check the medium
post it shows you how to do we work more
than 40 hour weeks
yep probably probably most people end up
but it's not none of its required which
Hill it's a real chill place to work
meet your deadlines be smart that's it
it's toughen girls worked for a while
depending any car flex right yep I have
to come from the community there's not
enough most cars on the common network
are Toyota's well we have to do
marketing define marketing is anything
we did today marketing I'm okay with
everything we did today if you're
talking about and I'd love to buy a
Super Bowl ad man this guy on the Super
Bowl that'd be crazy uh a quantum
supremacy I've seen that talked about a
bit lately
just come and make profit q4 we should
be profitable no I don't think other
companies are aware of what we've
accomplished at all I think if they
really knew how our models worked it's
unreal how far ahead it is um you know
what Tesla's doted Joe is that they talk
about I think it's what we already have
um about CNN oh yeah we in confidence
yeah Joe Rogan down a gondola
six minutes how does open pilot handle
uncertain traffic some reason it hasn't
seen before the new model is trained on
so much driving it's trained on tons and
tons of driving
do I think way mo is a good company it's
not that way mo is a bad company they're
just extremely overvalued we pitched to
investors one said not at the current
not at the valuation I wanted of course
I just demanded a random valuation off
the top of my head the other said
absolutely there a 16z and we went with
them they're great they're very good
there they are partners Chris Dixon
there it's good guy as you're talking to
that yeah
I will say this if I ever go on Joe
Rogan and he offers me some weed I will
smoke is deeper out a copy of open pilot
I don't even know what deep route is I
really parking sensors now , prime what
is it
check the medium post plan for lane
lines you were doing away with lane
lines tons of driving equal supervised
learning why are you so against
marketing a lot of its really scumming
if snots coming him I'm cool with it how
many people got the email by the way I
think we worked hard on that I'm pretty
happy with it I originally wanted to
make the subject re kangaroo what I
think of deep sky like musician was it
NACA higher test actually I think
published that to make it clear that
Tesla doesn't acquire companies for
overpriced yeah penny for marking in
2019 is not my grades uh you didn't get
the email cuz you guys bought eons I
think a long time ago oh you got the
email right someone got the email id
excellent um gonna need a good jingle
twenty-eight thousand one hundred and
ten dollars
mr. myrik thank you you bought yours
less than a month ago I don't know maybe
even opted into emails Oh we'll have to
figure it out a grape and it more
recently do you guys lose scale the io2
label stuff we got like seven things
labeled with them it's too expensive
it's too expensive to get like 10,000
images labeled would be $60,000 and
that's more than we can really pay if
they lower their prices 10x if they
figured out how to do that like they got
it to work with models we'd uh we'd use
them
I do enjoy San Diego in San Francisco I
think San Francisco's an overhyped scam
do I think test will get to level 5
automation next year no no and I will
bet big money that they do not it's not
to say that I actually think test was
the furthest along but if anybody would
like to bet the test little knock it to
level 5 in 2020 if you like to bet that
they would I'll take the other side of
that bet labeling and China should be
cheap Lola China's not even the place
for cheap labor anymore China's crazy
expensive though did I really sell my
soul I say I say when did we get comment
and sure earns oh in a while we didn't
work with via watch oh we didn't work
with via and that's the wonderful thing
about open pilot we didn't know that was
coming either guys this isn't about
partnerships this isn't about sketchy
backroom deals um this is about MIT
license code that anybody can use oh
well they we helped with the app yeah
they used our code they used our MIT
license code just like pronto used our
gray panda right like it's it's it's uh
it's not talking to us it's reading our
github I absolutely agree with what he
Lin said about liner yes anyone using
lidar is doomed ah two minutes guys no
one will have it by 2025 that bet I
wouldn't take 20 20 I would take I'm not
saying I think it will be but I wouldn't
take that
are there any restrictions to using MIT
license code basically you can't sue us
if it's shitty that's basically it
um how many sales seventy seventy well
let's let's actually check so we sold
seven impatience and then we can check
how many car harnesses we sold oh
there's three different types of car
harness
I think the bet goes until 3 p.m.
tomorrow I think Greg with 99 is
definitely gonna win um thoughts on deep
scale I don't know that much about
forest a few times I think I'm pretty
legit if Tesla didn't pay an exorbitant
price for them I think it's probably a
good deal I'm no comments on the EPS
firma right now well adjustable follow
distance ever come to stock Opie no
probably not
when will the next batch ship when we're
done making them won't be too long it
should be like once two weeks should be
actually should be with him it should be
a week after Monday I think we can make
like 50 a week um can you remove the
liability with the EPS firmware the prom
with the EPS firmware as it can be
dangerous it can be dangerous so we are
looking into it I understand I put I on
flashed the torque mod from this wreck
and it was terrible so I get it again
um no adjustable following distance I
don't think it's gonna be merged I think
that we need to address what you're
using it for in end-to-end longitudinal
and we just need to make we just need to
make open pilot better to the point that
you don't need that we do calculate gaze
direction with the front camera that is
part of our stuff works is anyone
working on flex right not a comma
because a bunch of external people join
the discord can a cop give you a ticket
absolutely you're completely liable at
all times and always remember guys pay
attention
um UI button to tag grid events yeah as
you dancing he's driving down a degree
worth it
I think most of the contents available
for free get opted you'll own control
maybe you guys look into it if it's good
that I would consider merging I live in
San Diego that's what common AI is Lane
hug like it's a motorcycle on the right
side need to hug the left lane
coming when we ship laying list check it
out zero six five I think it's actually
gonna be much better um walk so I missed
your thing how many FPS 20 fps we don't
sell the Hardison parts one price one
deal how smart is our team mad smart san
diego's pretty cool people sleeping at
Tesla's actually sneaky marketing it
might be the porn really was good for
get zero six five out yeah I got it I
got to go do that insurance is kind of
boring but yeah probably yeah we'll
probably have that installation
companies or dealerships dealerships but
if you want to be an installation
company you can actually do that right
now we have great bulk discounts on all
our products ETA four-lane list end of
the year with a lane hugging be
adjustable no it will not it'll just be
great stop signs and stoplights man will
later after Tesla ships them we'll look
into it before Tesla's ships them we're
not gonna look into it it's hard again
it's easy if your way Mon you can map
every one of them but if you want to
work at every stoplight and stop sign in
the country that's a lot harder but uh
you know the black panda has a
high-precision GPS so if we ever do ship
features like that you already got the
stuff you are going to need see how far
the Corolla can steer you got lock to
lock using gesture do ya the Corolla
torque is crazy Corolla is a super light
car and it's got like the same torque is
a rav4 we don't rent the server's we
bought them we got great prices on used
servers you sell your product in Panama
yes and it should absolutely work we
don't we cancelled the referral fee
program it didn't get more sales people
we'd hire more people when you try to
port more cars probably not almost all
our cars are Toyota and Honda but well
we'll get to him we got to make it
easier to port a car and this hardware
is a big step towards that do you go
spare time we're always working always
working bro I have tons of spare time
check my streams on Twitch does it work
well when it's driving on the Left we
have something probably coming for
left-handed driving you won't be
disappointed if you buy it I will say
that you can check out somebody up
other things but guys I'm already three
minutes overtime we're not hiring her
about what's the fanciest car with kama
installed no Igor's pretty nice
high trim Toyota Camry is pretty nice
what lane the car is in yes absolutely
it's accurate to a meter what car ports
are left really much yeah we got them
all
Tesla Tesla Tesla Tesla any Java down
position no we don't use Java older come
older Corolla and it's gonna be a ton of
work maybe if you replace the steering
column
can you put open pilot and Tesla yes and
people have done it check the discord um
Genesis is nice and nicer with Opie
that's right Oh Genesis is pretty nice
but that's actually not a bad choice a
bunch of Lexus's have it Corolla doesn't
have Android auto I know I know
come back soon zero seven zero seven by
the end of the year Bentley GT support I
don't think so alright guys thank you
for joining the final sales total is
twenty eight thousand nine hundred
fourteen dollars thank you all for
joining get your order in for common
harness you're gonna love it
$3.99 prices only go up you saw it here
thank you all for watching we'll take
one more look at the beautiful harness
Python is a dying language pythons girl
I'm mad fast and we're on Python 3 now
so it's great
alright see you all later bye-bye